you would hear the guns they would sound
really pretty loud
people turned out to watch because
they knew this was a life or death
struggle they've not been seen by the
public
for more than a hundred years ten
hand-drawn maps depicting the spanish
armada
were bought by a u.s collector last
summer but an export ban
allowed the national museum of the royal
navy in portsmouth
to keep them in england after raising
six hundred thousand pounds
in just eight weeks you've got to say
well there's only one opportunity
so let's seize it go for it we thought
that the story is such an incredible
story
that people would support us and sure
enough the great british public
contributed 100 000 pounds towards the
purchase of these
maps the maps were last bought at
auction
in 1903 for 90 pounds
purposely simple it's to tell the story
and
then as now one picture is worth a
thousand words
the maps are a snapshot of one of the
most significant
naval battles in history
you would have felt the rumble of cannon
fire being stood on this beach in
portsmouth
as the english and spanish fought on the
other side
of the isle of wight historians hope
that these maps
will bring to life this piece of history
for another generation
a lot of people have the understanding
that the spanish armada
was sort of spotted off of plymouth and
then they know about the famous
uh engagements off of sort of the kent
coast but actually it went all the way
up through the channel
and being able to see the layout of the
ships in this famous crescent shape
will really give us some more
understanding especially for for younger
generations
i feel excited because there's so much
stuff that you can learn
the maps will go on display when the
museum can reopen
bringing a new insight to this battle
more than 400 years
since the armada fought close by
tom whitehead sky news in portsmouth